the first question that I have to you is
what is learning any ideas
sure a schmuck Yussef learning is making
mistakes and identifying mistakes and
future steps any other definitions of
learning how would you define learning
building skills yes and so I looked it
up in the dictionary this is the
dictionary definition it's oh I'm
blocking it it's the acquisition of
knowledge or skills so study experience
or being taught so let me give you an
example like reading is that's something
that you learn yes okay so what about
growing your nails or growing your hair
y-yeah and so here here's there's a very
important distinction that I want to
make between something being programmed
versus something being learned so for
example if you look at humans there are
some things that are already programmed
these are things that are in your genes
so for example growing your hair
breathing blood flow repairing your
wounds digesting food and so on all of
these things are encoded on your genes
and so you didn't learn them because you
are programmed with it
and then there's all these other things
that you learned after you are born so
reading writing language driving a car
writing code going to the gym all of
this stuff are things that you learned
so it's things they acquire through
experience okay so given that let's look
a little bit closer into how humans
actually learn so this is a baby
learning to read and if you think about
maybe when you're 3 or 4 when you're
introduced to reading you're learning by
example so you would see oh this is an a
this is a B this is a C you'll see
thousands and thousands and thousands of
examples over time and then your brain
is able to generate
why's it you're able to see that all
these different variations are a even
though you've never seen those before
like I can tell that this is an a the
crocodile of the bird inside I can tell
that this is an a I may have never seen
this font before that this is an a that
the a with the two eyeballs on top is an
a I'm able to identify all of these
things because your brain is very very
powerful at seeing the different
patterns the general pattern of an a and
seeing it everywhere else and so if I
come back to machines what is machine
learning it's actually the exact same
thing
it's the acquisition of knowledge or
skills through study or experience by a
machine there really is no difference
between humans and machines as far as
learning goes the exact same rules apply
one extra definition that would be
helpful for you is the ability for the
ability for machines to learn without
being explicitly taught this actually
doesn't apply just to computers it
applies to humans as well as we
mentioned some things in you are
programmed in your genes and everything
else is learned okay so we talked about
how humans learn the difference between
programmed and versus learned what
machine learning is at a super high
level but why should we care like why
does it matter why should machine
learning exist why should we even bother
with this well it turns out that there's
a lot of problems where it's very
difficult to program but it's actually
much easier to learn for example what is
this it's a treat you have no problem in
identifying that this is a tree okay but
how would you define a tree let's see if
we can program this it's a fracture a
fracture oh a fractal
okay any other definitions of a tree
branches and leaves well what is a
branch yeah sure well what is a branch
can you define a branch
okay it's a brown pipe well what about
this one
is this not a branch but it's not brown
yeah well they never get said it
fellow-sufferer this is where it gets
like really complicated so if I say yeah
yes sir it does have a pattern but some
of them don't grow like this some of
them are more pointy and shorter for
example if you said okay maybe it's like
a brown trunk what leaves this wouldn't
be a tree and this would be a tree but
it's actually not and you can clearly
tell that this is not and so there's so
many different problems like this but
it's very very difficult to actually
identify or define the problem but you
as a human don't have a problem in
learning it but it's extremely difficult
to define and it turns out that looking
into the brain your brain is actually a
supercomputer that is able to the way
it's able to easily identify these
things is through billions and billions
of neurons that is in your brain for
example the part the part that is
responsible for seeing in your brain the
primary visual cortex that alone has a
hundred and forty million neurons and
tens of billions of connections and so
all these different connections are
somehow able to see to tell that this is
a tree and this is an A and this is a
human and this is a building and this is
this is just one layer of six different
layers that are inside your brain your
brain is a supercomputer and so if we
dig inside a little bit your brain is
hackable for example if you look closely
at this picture your brain will get
confused sometimes because you'll see
that this is a spiral but this is
actually four perfect circles so your
brain is used to specific things but at
the same time it is not perfect you can
hack it just like you can hack a machine
as well so what is inside the brain now
that is largely unknown but what we know
so far is that a brain has these
building blocks called neurons and these
neurons have a state they can either be
on or
and these neurons are connected to other
neurons with connections called synapses
so these connections are used to
transfer information from one unit to
the next and a neuron can turn off or on
neighboring neurons and so at any given
point in time there's a configuration in
your head of neurons that are turned on
and are turned off and these somehow map
to the thoughts and whatever things that
you see and hear and touch but how that
fully works remains not fully understood
but it seems like the more neurons that
we have the more neurons and synapses
that one would have the more computing
power and the more intellect that you
can have so let's look at different
brains out in the nature so this is a
sponge how many neurons does a sponge
have in its brain any guesses zero yeah
you actually got that right a sponge has
no brain what about a jellyfish any
guesses no it does tree does have a
green it has a green a couple of million
actually thought less than that it's
5600 neurons so it's a super super small
brain what about a cockroach no you're
good at this it's exactly 1 million
neurons
okay what about a mouse I can't do a
billion
it's a 71 million close 71 million
neurons and about a trillion synapses
what about a pigeon
two orders of magnitude so like it's a
little less it's a little less yes
so it's 310 million neurons for the
pigeon this is a cat it's not a pigeon
okay how many yes okay so a Celt let's
see a cat has 760 million and around ten
trillion synapses gorillas any guesses
1 billion it's more it's way more it's
more than 10 billion it is 33 billion
actually close ok and then humans less
than less than yes let's not get into
them ok
no it's less close so we're actually at
around 86 billion neurons and around 150
trillion synapses now our humans so
actually the baby has less neurons but
as an adult it's about 86 billion now
there are creatures that have larger
brains but it's not clear why they're
not necessarily more intelligent this is
why I'm saying it's still largely
unexplored but we can see that there's
generally a correlation between the more
neurons and synapses you have with more
computational power that's in the brain
so one type of dolphin has a
significantly larger brain I don't I'm
not sure it might in Milan yes but for
example there are types of element
elephants and dolphins that have three
times as many neurons as humans but
there are different theories of why it's
not more intelligent one theory is where
the neurons are in the brain matters so
the part that really matters for
abstract thought it's called the
cerebral cortex in humans that have they
have around 16 billion neurons for
elephants that have much larger brain
they have 6 billion neurons so it's a
much smaller
cortex but all these are conjectures
they're not proven yep okay so we talked
a little bit of theory about there's
this something called the brain and
there's these things called neurons and
synapses that somehow are able to
recognize patterns and identify trees
and see things just like we humans do
now it's time to actually take this into
some code so we're actually gonna write
we're gonna see how we can use a brain
this is gonna be very analogous to the
brain in nature and so the first thing
I'm gonna do we're gonna get you set up
shortly but I want to actually
demonstrate the code first so that you
can see how this all fits together now
this is gonna closely map to the example
of humans human learning that we talked
about before so in a human you see a
human reading the alphabet you see
thousands and thousands of examples of
characters and then from that you infer
the general structure of what an a looks
like what a B looks like and so forth so
if you want to do this with a machine is
it okay if I I am recording the screen I
got you and so if we want to do this
with humans can you hear me guys at the
back a little bit okay so if we want to
do the same thing with humans the first
thing we have to do is to get a data set
a data set is gonna be a data file work
contains all the different examples of
whatever it is that we want to teach so
in this example we're actually gonna
teach a brain to understand digits it's
gonna be able to recognize a picture
it's gonna you're gonna give it a
picture of a number and it's gonna tell
you what this number is so the first
thing is we would get the data set now I
already have it downloaded I'll get into
the details of how you can do this on
your machine in a second and the second
thing we're gonna do is I'm just gonna
load a bunch of libraries that I'll also
get into and more individually but the
first thing I'm going to do is the load
the digits and it's loading an asterisk
here means that it's
running okay so it has finished running
and if I look at this this is 60,000
images and the image sizes are 28 by 28
so let's take a look at what's inside
this dataset so here is an example of
some of the images that we have so this
is a data set of Arabic digits and each
one has a label so this image image of
the number three has the label three
this has a four fives and so forth and
notice how deceivingly complicated this
problems or deceivingly simple it's
actually quite a complicated problem
look at the difference between this five
and this five you don't have it you
don't have a problem in identifying that
both of these are fives but they're
actually written very differently and as
an image it looks very different okay so
we took a look at this dataset and now
the next thing we're gonna do is this is
what the image you wouldn't be able to
see it well here let me see if i zoom
out yeah so this is the matrix of what
each image looks like this is what this
is what the brain actually sees so this
is a 28 by 28 image and each number here
is the pixel value of that image if you
look closely you can almost see the
number 9 in this this is what the brain
is actually processing okay and so the
next thing we're gonna do is actually
gonna teach the brain so in this case we
have 60,000 images as I mentioned and
now we're going to create a brain and
then we're gonna make this brain learn
we're gonna give it the images and the
labels with that image and so what is
actually happening happening now this is
the brain as its learning and the
background the two things that I want
you to pay attention to are the the
accuracy I don't know if can you guys
see this number
yes so this is at 96% so right now it's
saying that based on what it has based
on the study and the learning that it
has done so far it has learned it has
gotten 96% of it correctly and as you go
by you'll notice that this accuracy is
getting better and better and better
over time so how does this work in sight
this is what we were going to be
discussing in the next day tomorrow but
for the purpose of today I actually want
you to learn how to use this so the next
thing is now once this brain has learned
let's actually see if it has learned
well we're gonna test it and so I'm
gonna load some images and these images
the brain has never seen before so I
just loaded it and let's look at one of
these images so here I just Lommel it
loaded test image number 18 and so this
is the image that we have now let's run
it by the brain and see what it will
give us so here I would do a brain dot
predict and I give it the image and then
look at the prediction and in this case
it tells me that it is innate so I was
able to identify that this is an image
now let me get instead of just
predicting one image I'm gonna predict
all the images so here predicted 10,000
images and here are the predictions and
now let's actually get a sense of like
where this brain is going wrong let's
see which ones we messed up we didn't
get correctly so here I'm figuring out
which ones are incorrect and then I'm
gonna take a look okay so these are some
of the things that got wrong and you'll
notice that some of these things are
genuinely hard for example this this I
was actually a zero at thought it was a
five it actually looks like a five but
who never wrote it meant to write a zero
let's see
this was also a five
but it predicted it to be a zero because
it was more like a big dot this was
actually a three but for whatever reason
addicted a zero I guess because it was
very very clustered this one it
predicted it to be a zero because when
it cooked when you look at it closely
it's more like a dog like the Arabic
zero so looking at this gives you a
sense of okay what is it that the brain
is having in trouble with and these look
like it's genuinely hard like I have no
idea what this is but it says it's an
eight home ever wrote it it actually it
is an eight now that I know that you
would tell me what it is
so this was a sanity check to see that
the brain is actually working properly
and it's almost comparable to human
performance like some of these things I
would struggle in identifying as numbers
okay so the first thing that we want to
do now now I showed you how you can are
a very simple example of a brain
learning Arabic digits we're gonna do
two things one is we're going to set up
the environment yesterday and we'll make
it work and actually run this code and
this next thing is we're gonna move on
to an exercise where instead of us
teaching it Arabic digits we're gonna be
teaching it English digits and to give
you some sure third one this one this
one this one so the actual was zero and
the predicted was an eight so yeah I
that looks like an eight to me too but
whomever wrote it wrote it with the
intention of it being a zero
[Music]
yeah so so in this particular case I
think because there was a dot like the
person put in a dot and then it's
smudged a little bit and then it ended
up looking like an 8 so in a typical
scenario you as a human would mistake it
for an 8 I mistake it for an 8 and so
this is where machines and humans sort
of become comparable learning is not
perfect in this case but as long as we
see that the things that got wrong are
things that are genuinely hard then this
is a sign that it learned well any other
questions about this so far
yeah so the actual is a five and then
asada was a zero because it was very
round
no they were all yeah that's a good
question so I'm not sure how this
dataset was particularly prepared my
guess is it wasn't my guess is the zero
was scaled a little bit and maybe that
was part of the that was part of the
problem like if you look at some of the
the zeros they're actually quite big
very large dots okay any other questions
about this so far okay so if you have
gotten the repository for this for this
workshop I think you should do a good
pull because I've made some last-minute
changes but the repository will have the
brain that we're gonna be using to learn
it'll have this file that you'll be able
to run and what I'm running here you may
have asked what is this thing that I'm
running into this is a called a Jupiter
notebook think of a Jupiter notebook as
a place where I can write text or I can
have a notebook but at the same time I
can have code that executes so whenever
I go to a code block I can write like
shift enter and then it executes that
code like when I say when I rerun this
it's gonna get another random sample and
show it so this is an easier way for you
to test things out and for me to
pinpoint some of the codes and then I
can rewrite I can rerun different lines
of the code as well okay
so I want to get started on get the
repository and then what you're gonna do
if you have everything set up what you
should be doing is you're going to go to
the root package of your repository and
then you're gonna type
I'll make this bigger Jupiter notebook
and what this is gonna what this is
going to what this is gonna do is it's
going to open up this notebook interface
that we have and then you can open up
Arabic digits and then you can just
click on Play and that's gonna run the
code and then you'll get to see it
okay so shall we do this okay
no one's excited guys okay yes the
command would be yes so this should be
their command okay
here
so if you had things set up this command
should work Hey yeah this one
cool
okay
you
but
we'll get started that everyone set up
their environment from yesterday there's
anyone still having problems okay
perfect
perfect so hopefully today will go a lot
smoother so I'm gonna give a big in what
a recap of some of the theory that we
talked about yesterday so one thing that
we talked about yesterday was how humans
learn versus how machines learn and so
if you look at a comparison in humans
you start by observing the world and the
example that we used a child learning
how to read you see the different
letters yet in school when you're
walking on the street and so forth and
then your brain is able to capture what
the general pattern of each of these
letters look like and the machine is
almost exactly the same thing but
because the machine usually isn't
wandering around the world looking at it
you give it a data set so we load a data
set and then we build a brain because a
machine doesn't have a brain and then we
teach it so that it can identify the
general pattern so yesterday we walk
through an example of that brain
learning Arabic digits and there was an
exercise of trying to teach it to learn
English digits so I realized I skimmed
through the code yesterday a little too
quickly so I'm gonna go walk through
that code again and then we're gonna
move forward to how this brain actually
works under the hood okay so the first
thing I'm gonna do I'm gonna get into my
terminal now this is the directory of
the repository that I have and then what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna run this thing
called Jupiter now think of Jupiter as a
place for you to write notebooks
it's like notepad but the difference is
that I can put blocks of code inside
this notebook and I can execute blocks
of code inside this notebook so I'm
gonna open up Arabic digits and if you
remember what we mentioned before the
first thing that we would do is we would
get a data set so
the machine would know what it is that
we want to teach so there was a data set
that we gave the link to which hopefully
you've all downloaded and then what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to take this data
set and then you see in the repository
there's a folder here called data sets
and then there's another folder called
Arabic digits and then you're supposed
to paste all the files there in the zip
file into this folder so that way the
code that we have will be able to know
where to read the files okay so let's
have a look at these files like what is
inside these CSV files are you guys all
familiar with a CSV file is okay so
let's look at train images so here you
can see this is a file that has 60,000
rows and each row has comma separated
values it has it actually has 784 values
and it's corresponding to the 784 pixels
in the image so it's the pixel intensity
of each value in that image and so what
we do is when we go to Jupiter first we
import some libraries that we'll be
using throughout and I'm getting an
error of some sort let me see
oh I did not actually go into my
environment so so I need to do on Mac a
would be source activate the name of the
environment and I'll workshop if you're
on Windows it's just activate and I'll
workshop ok and you can see that it
actually got in the environment because
you should see it the name of the
environment right here ok now I'm going
to rerun Jupiter close this ok reopen
Arabic digits let's reinforce all this
stuff ok so now it has worked and now
we're going to load the Arabic digits so
this is opening the CSV file and then
it's putting all of these images in
memory now what do these things look
like in memory let's take a look so the
way for you to take a look at this you
can see the shape of the data there just
typing that the name of the variable dot
shape and you see here just like the
file we opened it has 60,000 images and
each one is 28 by 28 and so here is a
sample image and we we saw this before
why she lives so this is the matrix
that's it it's a two-dimensional matrix
of the numbers in an image you can
almost see the number down here exactly
and the label the corresponding label
should just be the number line okay now
once you know the data set if it's
pictures that's always a good idea to
visualize things throughout I don't
think people that are doing machine
learning
visualizing things as much as they
should and so this is a little function
that I gave you you give it the images
and the labels and it will pick some
random images to show you so you can get
a feel of this dataset and so here as we
mentioned before these are the 28 by 28
images and just above them is the
corresponding people so seven seven one
and you can notice the different
variations like between the 6 and the 6
and the two 7s this is the general
pattern that this brain is meant to
understand and if I rerun this again you
should get a different sample so feel
free when you're going through the code
to check that out okay so now we've
loaded the data set and now because a
machine doesn't have a brain we're going
to create this little object that I
called brain what is it that's something
that we're gonna talk about shortly but
for now
it is a green so we bring a brain and
then we're gonna make it learn we're
gonna give it images and the labels and
so now it's started learning and you'll
see we had 60,000 images we put 48,000
images to train on and 12,000 images
what is called validation so here we've
split the data into 80% 48,000 images
for training for the brain to look at
and to recognize the pattern in and then
the other 20% the 12,000 images this is
used to test to see how good this brain
is and so as the brain is learning it's
actually learning the training examples
and you'll see here is the accuracy
you're starting at 96% and the more you
learn the better it gets so here you end
up at ninety nine point three percent
but the number that actually matters
more is the validation accuracy so this
is the 20% of the data set that the
brain didn't look
and so here it varies between 97% and
98.5 percent so this is actually looking
pretty good and to see further okay what
is it that this brain houses brain
performing there is another data set
that the brain never looked at this is
always a good idea to actually test the
true performance of that brain so we're
gonna load that dataset and again always
a good idea to visualize I'm gonna plot
the image or one of the images so this
is one of the images that I have and now
I go to axe to the brain
this was images test 18 I'm gonna ask
the brain give me a prediction what do
you think what do you think this is and
I look at the value of that prediction
it is an 8 so it has correctly
identified it as an 8 so in this case
this was performing it out like 98% so
it's already doing really well but let's
look at what is it that it's not doing
so well so the first thing I'm gonna do
is instead of just predicting that one
image I'm gonna predict all the images
that are in that data set and to figure
out how many images are in that data set
that I can just do images test dot what
the people don't know dot shape we use
that shape because this is a
multi-dimensional this is not just an
array it's a multi-dimensional
so here we have 10,000 images 28 by 28
okay so we're gonna pass in the images
test notice we didn't pass the labels
just the images and then it's gonna give
us its predictions and then here this is
shorthand to say tell us the indices
where the labels that we have didn't
match the predictions and so we're gonna
run that code initially let's see how
many
wrong so here I can do incorrect
dot sorry so we're gonna visualize in a
second but here I'm just getting a sense
of how many they are so here there's we
got two hundred and eighty five images
that were incorrect
okay so let's visualize what is actually
happening okay let's see so if we look
at this one the actual one if we look at
this one the actual was a five but I
thought it was a nine and this seems
like a reasonable thing to do because
the five here it has this like squiggle
so it almost looks like a nine this
seems like a reasonable thing to do if
you look at this one the actual was the
three but it thought it was a two
because they were close enough like the
edges weren't really there this one
doesn't look like a four at all but it's
supposed to be a four so it seems this
is what you tell if you see results like
this the model is actually doing pretty
well because some of these things are
genuinely hard but if you look at this
and say like okay this seems really easy
then it means like you should be worried
something could be not right with your
model so yeah
so if you look at its possible
so more training in most cases shouldn't
hurt but it's not necessarily going to
get better like you'll realize well
let's see that's yeah that is true let's
see well let's see let's look at another
one let's look at another sample 169 yep
so so he has a better brain because it
happened that his brain learned better
in this case okay well in these examples
it's actually they seem plausible like
that one that it's at the very top right
it's way too tilted the four is also way
too squiggled the seven is like way too
thick this seems reasonable but yes
probably more training would solve this
problem that makes sense okay so this
was some of the things that we talked
about yesterday and an exercise which I
was hoping to get to yesterday but
didn't because the setup took a little
bit while is now with the knowledge that
we know here can we teach that same
brain no changes to learn English digits
so the exercise
I'll show you let me just figure on this
if I go to exercise one you'll find this
any repository as well so this data set
is closed so this data set is hosted on
a website called Kegel and this is
actually a competition so this is a
competition
Oracle is a website for hosting machine
learning competitions so if you go to
Kegel you'll actually find dozens and
dozens of really cool competitions and
some of them have
prize money of like a hundred thousand
dollars if you get the best machine
learning model for it
so some of the competition's you'll see
is identifying whether or not there is a
tumor in an image
or trying to give in an image with a car
to figure out where the car is and strip
it out of the image very interesting
stuff so if you have the time check that
out
so one of the competition's that they
have for starters is the digit
recognizer image so this is a data set
with English digits so we're gonna
download that dataset and then we're
gonna do a very similar thing to what we
did before we're gonna load the data set
and what was the one tip I mentioned
about working with data sets something
that a lot of people don't do when
working with images visualizing yes so
so here I put it to do the visualize so
let's go ahead and do that and so
visualize the show example and here I'm
gonna pass it the images as well as the
labels ok so it looks very similar to
the other data set that we have said
this in English okay and now we're going
to build the brain and all we had to do
for this exercise was we're gonna use
the brain object that we have before so
I'm gonna go ahead and create a new
object brain and then I'm going to make
a brain learn from the images
cool so it's starting to learn exactly
the same processes we had before so here
let's split the data set 80% of it went
into training the other 20% it's using
for validation and notice at the
beginning here and had a bit of a poor
start of that 92% and then over time it
has bumped up to 98% and ID and here in
95 all the way to 97 so comparable
performance this is the same brain we
didn't change anything about it just
like a human brain one brain is speaks
Arabic another speaks Hindi or whatever
language it is ok so let's test it out
so I'm gonna load some test images and
also what's the tip that I asked for 30
seconds ago we're gonna visualize again
always visualize sure I'm gonna give it
some of the images tests ok so they look
pretty similar well this one might be a
bit hard to predict and then we're
actually going to ask our brain to do
predictions so I'm gonna run it and ask
it to predict and then give it the test
images
kidding we're getting in here of some
sort
oh I said I should have predict many so
predict was for a single image predict
many is for multiple images okay so it
has predicted of all 28,000 images let's
see what this looks like so here this is
an array of 28,000 numbers each one
would be corresponding to the prediction
of the equivalent image in the images
test now the final thing is we actually
don't have the labels for these images
meaning that I don't know how much how
well it actually did for these images
and that's the whole point of that
competition on Cagle you will build a
brain and then you would train it and
then they give you a test data that's
unlabeled and then you give the
predictions from your brain and then you
give it a kegel and we'll give you a
score so here I wrote a little function
for you that is going to take these
predictions and then it's gonna write a
file called submission dot CSV so if I
go back to my repository okay it's right
here no it was just modified today and
this is what the submission file looks
like
so the idea each image as well as the
label that our brain thinks is correct
so we're gonna take the CSV and then you
can go to Cagle submit predictions and
then here you can upload I was gonna be
challenging with one hand
[Music]
you're gonna upload your submission dot
CSV and then you click make submission
and now it's actually checking against
the labels because it knows the right
the correct values and it gives you a
score oh and here I am
I got a 97 around 97% not the best
because some people got much much higher
scores but it's not pretty good and so
if you go through that notebook exercise
1 you will be able to make a submission
on kekel you should not if you haven't
done so already okay cool so that was
the material that I wanted to cover
yesterday if you haven't been through
the exercise please do and now we're
actually going to get into a little bit
more theory and maybe one obvious
question that you've had as I was going
through this is what is this brain thing
that we've been using and so this gets
back to one thing that we talked about
yesterday the brain can consisting of
neurons and synapses and what we know
that in this thing you have over 80
billion neurons that are connected with
each other with trillions of connections
about 150 trillion of them and that each
neuron it has a state so a neuron can be
active or inactive and a neuron can
transmit messages to neighboring neurons
to activate them or deactivate them so
at any point in time there's a
configuration in your brain of which
neurons are active and which ones are
not active and somehow this is an app to
your thoughts and the more neurons that
you have and more synapses in theory you
should have more computational power
okay so let's go back to the very simple
building block of what is in Iran and
here we're gonna move from biology to
computers so let's start with what an
Iran is in the land of computers so in
Iran is the building block that we'll be
using and you can think of it as
something that takes in an input it
could be one input can be many inputs
and it makes a decision whatever that
decision is so let's look at an example
let's say I want to figure out whether I
should study computer science or not so
there are several factors that go into
that decision let's say do I think this
is an interesting field that's an
important factor are there jobs
available after I graduate is there a
good school that's nearby and close to
home so these are all factors that would
help me make that decision and so here
I'm gonna take all of these factors I'm
gonna put them in variables so for the
first factor I'm gonna call it x1 second
factor X to the third factor x3 and I'm
gonna give the variable a 1 if the
answer to that question is a yes I'm
gonna give it a 0 if the answer is
unknown so for example let's say I think
computer science is interesting and
there are jobs but the school isn't
close to home what would be the values I
didn't hear that
one 1 0 that's right let's try another
example there are great jobs in computer
science but there isn't a school nearby
and I don't find that interesting
0 1 0 is this clear to everyone
ok so we've taken the factors that we
have and we encoded it into
variables the next thing we're gonna do
is so these are the factors we're
feeding and tour in Iran and the neuron
is gonna take these three things and
make a decision but how are we going to
make that decision well one way we can
do it is using what we call a decision
function and this is what we're gonna
use so we're gonna sum up all the X's
that are here and if the value of this
sum is above a certain threshold we'll
say yes and if it's less than or equal
to that threshold we'll say no it makes
sense so far
any questions cool so threshold here is
a bit bulky so I'm just gonna rephrase
threshold the theta cool okay so let's
look at the examples that we've had
before let's see and I set the threshold
to be one okay I think you're beautiful
there are jobs but the school isn't
close to home we've already mentioned
how this is encoded x 1 is 1 x 2 is 1 x
3 is 0
now based on this decision function what
should be my decision
y yes exactly
so I some yes I sound them all up
exactly
so I summed them all out it's 2 which is
greater than the threshold so I should
go okay no second example there are good
jobs in computer science there isn't a
school nearby and I don't find it that
interesting you should not go yes
so in this case it equals 1 which is
less than or equal to theta and so I
wouldn't go to computer science and you
see it's a neuron has a very simple
thing but it's able to capture simple
decision models ok let's look at a more
abstract example so let's say I want to
implement an
or gate so in this case I have two
inputs x1 and x2 so I have whenever
they're both 0
the decision is 0 and for all the other
states if any of them is 1 my decision
will be 1 so now I need to find out a
value of theta that would make this true
and so let's say I should say that to be
0.5 does this work well let's see so at
0 and 0 our at the moment is 0 which is
less than 0.5 and so the decision is 0
as expected at 0 1 x1 plus x2 is 0 plus
1 which is 1 also which is greater than
0.5 greater than my threshold and so
it's yes for 1 and 0 that's the same
thing and for one on one the sum is 2
it's greater than 0.5 so my decision is
1 and so one neuron was able to
implement an or gate and one way to
visualize this is these are the four
points that we've had here the white
ones are where I want the decision to be
won the black dot is where I want it to
be 0 and when I put theta to be 0.5 I'm
actually drawing a line that separates
the white circles from the black circles
this is the line where things equal
theta
so here it's at 0.5 and here's that
point 5 any questions so far
make sense ok let's try an end gate we
also need to figure out a theta to make
it work let's say we do any guesses
actually and what theta could be more
than one that's correct
so yes exactly exactly
and so if we choose theta to be equals
1.5 looks like
examples 0 0 less than 1.5 so that's the
decision is your own at 0 1 it's less
than 1.5 so I just a 0 X 1 and X 2 it's
also less than 1.5 1 and 1 it's 2 which
is greater than 1.5 so the decision is 1
and notice 1.5 isn't the only solution
like 1.1 could have worked 1.2 or even
yeah exactly exactly exactly and again
visualizing it in the case of the end we
only want this value to be decision 1
and so we've moved the line from where
it was for the or to here separating the
white circles on one side the black
circles on the other okay let's try
another example and in this case I want
to implement an XOR so an X 4 in case
you don't remember you only want the
decision to be 1 1 only one of the
values is 1 different digits what do you
mean
to
meaning different digits oh yes yes
exactly like this
this is correct right so what would it
motivated me that would work for this
well so that actually won't work that
won't work
between two values I mean yeah I think I
think you're actually pretty close so if
you look at if you look at this
visualization there's something
different there's something different
about this then say the end notice that
in the case at the end I was able to
draw a line that separates the white
we're decision is one on one side and
the decision is zero on the other side
and the or was the same thing
you can't yes exactly but you can't have
a curve in upper in a neuron so and
you're on a single neuron can't capture
this I can't do an XOR with a neuron
it's not possible but what is possible
there's more than one neuron so I'll put
two lines and I'll say everything that's
between these two lines is gonna be a
wide circle and everything outside of
them is black and so how are we gonna
implement this remember this line this
was the same or line that we had before
so yeah so there's an or we know there's
an or yeah yes there corresponds to an
or and this was an end the end line that
we had but the end line is different
because the end made all the the circles
on this side white and this one black we
want the reverse of that and so to do
that
we'll put everything will be will be a
knot and basically you'll reverse
everything and then you want things to
be the ones that are to the right of
this one and the ones to the left of
this one and so we end these two results
and you'll get your decision and so if I
expand this we've built an or
we've built an end so the full neural
network gives the member donna321 five
the end theta 1 point 5 for the knot and
I actually took the negative of the
inputs and I put in the negative of the
theta this is how you can do a knot in a
neuron and the UCSC in this case I took
a very simple neuron that's capable of
doing very simple decisions and I put
them together in blocks to solve
something that's more complex and so you
can imagine these are three neurons if I
put hundreds or thousands or millions or
in the case of your brain billions and
billions of them it is able to do things
that are much much much more complicated
like recognizing digits like singing
like dancing like driving a car and so
forth okay so a couple of things that I
wanted to cover if I go back to the
original example some of these things
again generally there are so many cases
where some of these factors are more
important than others for example maybe
I think the fact that if the subject is
interesting it matters a lot more that
there is a school close to home and so
to represent that yes with weights
exactly so we're gonna be introducing
weeds and so every connection that you
see here will be weighted and so instead
of the decision function just being
these sons of the exes it becomes the
access times the W's so be doing X 1
times W 1 x 2 times they'll be 2 times 3
times away 3 and something those are up
and checking if it's greater than or
equal to the threshold any questions so
far
okay so let's try an example I think
computer science that was the example we
had before we've encoded it to x1 x2 but
let me add I only care about getting a
job after I graduate and I don't care
about anything else yeah yeah so what
should the weights be yeah 0 1 0 or 0 10
0 it doesn't matter what w2 is as long
as it's positive ok for the same example
what if I say be interested in the
subject is very important to me and I
actually want to move too so it's better
if the school is far away
[Music]
so if I do a zero for the second one it
means that I don't care about jobs one
well but I do care I do care about jobs
but yeah and so for this one so here I
actually want the opposite so the
opposite of this and let the opposite of
this
so w3 should be a negative number and
this should be a greater number than
this one it doesn't matter what the
values are so 2 1 negative 1 2010 -15 as
long as just that as long as you're
having the right ratios that's what
matters
ok now you might be wondering ok we've
shown how to have a neural group of
neurons to create decisions sometimes
more complicated decisions but where's
the learning like how does this tie to
actually learning things so learning is
figuring out which parameters and
thresholds to use so in the case of the
digits problem that we did with Arabic
and English they are the same network of
neurons the only difference is that we
chose different weights and different
thresholds and the connections to make
it learn Arabic versus learn English but
it's the same network structure and so
this is what learning is and this is
also what learn he is inside the human
brain as far as we know as far as I know
so in this case we have four parameters
we have three weights and a theta what
about this one how many parameters do we
have this was the neural network or they
could and group of neurons by the way is
known as a neural network for it was
more there's an item so every connection
here has a week 1 2 3 4 5 6 and there
are 3 thresholds to figure out as well
so it's a total of nine or
I notice here we've made a made a leap
we've actually changed the learning
problem into an optimization problem
which is something that has been studied
for a long time and so here we want to
choose the parameters the weights and
the thresholds to minimize our error but
what is the error you can define the
error in whatever way you like so one
definition for the error could be the
mean squared error which is I look at
what is the correct value and what is
the predicted value and I take the
square of the difference but you can
have different values that you can have
different error functions as well and
you'll need an algorithm that takes this
error and tweaks the weights and
thresholds to minimize the error and so
one there are several algorithms again
to use but one very common one is called
stochastic gradient descent this was all
right as will demonstrate in the code
surely this is something that we'll be
using to actually optimize these weights
now how does this algorithm work and the
definition of this I think that'll be
too deep for this session I would rather
you to focus on the high level code of
how to use these different building
blocks to build neural networks to learn
things but there are plenty of resources
to look into maybe this is something you
can do in the future if people are
interested okay
so another thing is we said that a
decision function is the summing the
axis times weights and it has the value
of one when it's greater than a
particular threshold and zero when it's
less than a particular threshold so it's
a step function but sometimes the
decisions aren't always this binary it's
not like I'm gonna study computer
science study computer science and then
I'm gonna I'm all-in and I'll study
everything that I can in computers
usually like varying degrees and so you
can use different decision functions
depending on how you want your neuron to
behave so for example there these are
some functions that you will see when
you look at code bases of machine
learning so sigmoid values softmax this
is what a sigmoid function looks like
for example and so it's good to use the
sigmoid function in your decisions
because then you'll have a degree of
confidence in your decision as opposed
to yes or no so sigmoid is one of the
functions that you can use as well okay
so we talked about neurons we showed how
neurons are grouped together to make
more complex decisions we mentioned that
a group of neurons is a neural network
now we're gonna talk about what is the
neural network that we used to recognize
digits in those examples so we took an
image 28 by 28 image 24 pixels and this
is the label that we're using so here
this is actually a vector of ten digits
and this is saying that the label is
seven so I'm putting zero for everything
and I'm putting one for the value of
seven that I want and I'll explain why
we do this in a minute and then the
first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna flatten this two-dimensional
matrix I'm gonna make us just one long
784 by one vector and then we're gonna
build a layer of neurons in this case
I'm gonna add 512 neurons and I'm gonna
connect each one of these pixels to all
512 neurons so the first one is
connected to all 512 the second one
512 and so on and so forth and then I'm
gonna make another layer with 512
neurons and can i connect everything in
this layer to this layer the same way
and then finally I'll be doing what's
called the atomic bullet so here I'll
have 10 neurons and being helpful in
each of these neurons they're all
connected to this layer the output of
these neurons will be the probability
corresponding to that particular digit
being the correct digit so in the case
of 7 I expect the seventh note to have a
significantly higher value than all the
other ones so why two layers why did I
choose 512 neurons here there's
unfortunately no good answer to that so
there's nothing at least so far there is
no known science where you look at a
problem and you put it in a formula
tells you you should use two layers 512
neurons each and you're gonna get the
best output this is actually largely
unknown so right now people actually
they have heuristics on what would be
good like generally adding more layers
and gets better learning but it's at the
cost of slower training time but it's
largely an art and you try different
stuff and eventually see that patterns
emerge but putting that pattern into
science has yet to be done and it is
frustrating I know
so 512 was chosen at semi random you can
read some guidelines of some ways of
designing good neural networks but it
wouldn't be it's not a science there's
no exact reason why this is 512 and not
600 but today when you're building your
own neural networks you should try try
adding more layers try changing the
number of neurons try changing the
decision functions that we use try
changing the error and see how this
impacts your performance okay so we've
expressed the
the neural network that we build let's
look at the actual code sure yes that I
don't know the exact relationship like I
would I don't know if it's linear or not
but that is one thing that would be
worth testing out today for sure but to
give you a sense of the state of the art
that is there today for example there is
a very well-known competition called
imagenet where they would have many May
I think on the order of millions of
images and then you have to classify it
into a thousand different categories
like dogs and insects and plants and so
forth
and the state of the art of 2013 was a
model called vgg 19 and so it had 19
layers like this I don't know the exact
sizes but I'm sure it would be bigger
than 512 so it's massive and so training
a network of that size would take days
and you probably want to run it on GPUs
we're gonna be using the CPUs right now
you probably want to run it across
multiple machines it gets vastly more
complicated but digits they're simple
enough that you can run it on one
machine that's fast a train then it's a
much smaller problem so you don't need
neurons of that size many questions are
there questions okay so we're gonna jump
into the code and the machine learning
right we're gonna be using to do neural
networks
it's called Kiera's so you're gonna
start by importing carrots and then
first you're gonna define remember what
we talked about in a green actually when
you're writing in machine
learning terminology it's called the
model so the model is exactly what that
brain was that we talked about before
and I say it's a sequential sequential
basically means that it's a it's a
sequence of layers you can have a graph
where different layers are linking but
for the purposes of today it's all just
a sequence of layers so okay so it's a
sequential and now what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna flatten the input if you remember
the first step that we had we took the
image and we flattened it into one
vector so here and tell me if the input
is 28 by 28 and I'm flattening it to be
one vector the next thing is we had a
layer of 512 new runs and so I can do
that by saying dense dense is saying
connect all the 784 values that are here
to all these 512 neurons that are here
and the activation think about that's
the decision function that we were
talking about value is one of the
decision functions you don't have to use
it but it is actually the nice thing
about it is that it's it speeds up the
training so if you try other functions
that should still work but really you
generally is a good practice for middle
layers all talk more about that in a
second and then the next one we're gonna
have another layer of 512 so it's
exactly the same thing and then finally
we're gonna give it the last layer of
ten minutes now the last layer should be
corresponding to how many different
types of things you're labeling so in
the case of the digits we have ten
digits sorry yeah exactly zero to nine
sorry ten digits so I want 10 neurons to
be not output and here I'm choosing
softmax as my decision the reason we're
choosing softmax as opposed to something
else is that we want the outputs at
least 10 neurons
to be a probability so that's when user
soft max
this makes sure that all the some of
these neurons sums up to one and so when
you look at the output you can interpret
that as the probability for that neuron
to be equivalent to that corresponding
digits so this is the neural network
that we have and then finally this is
now that we've outlined the architecture
you want to tell it how do you measure
here and what algorithm that you want to
use to minimize the error and that's
what we're gonna do we're gonna use the
mean squared error as we talked about
before and the algorithm the optimizer
is sarcastic gradient descent and you
can optionally add another so you just
leave it at that then when you're
learning it's only gonna show you the
error which sometimes it's not as easy
to understand if you add accuracy if
your metrics it'll show you the
percentage of images that it got right
which ones they got wrong so this is an
extra to see and you can look up
appearance has a really good
documentation so you can look into what
is dense how it works what are the
different activation functions that you
can use what are the different loss what
are the different optimizers that you
can use you can try all these different
configurations on various data sets that
are out there on cattle or otherwise and
explore how that actually changes things
you can add more later there's a lot of
things that you can play with here so if
I put this code in the English digits it
should work if I go back
so I'm just gonna copy this
and I'm going to go here yeah restart
okay okay so this was the English data
set that we had before this is double
check this is the one
I didn't love the Dennison
okay and here I'm just gonna paste in
that code
so here I've made my model and this is
actually code that I didn't talk about
and I'm considering leaving it for you
to figure out what it is because
otherwise the exercise will be way too
easy but think of this code block as
what's gonna is the equivalent of
actually making it learn and so now it's
learning and here I used actually
different error and optimizers in the
brain Python file so this one actually
is training because I use different
algorithms this algorithm is actually a
little slower so you'll see it's
starting at 20 percent as opposed to the
96 percent that we had before but it's
slow it's catching up slowly so here
it's a 78 percent now it's getting to 85
and if we give it enough time it'll get
to similar levels that we've had before
okay so now we're gonna move on to
exercise 2 and in this exercise there is
another data set on cat go if the
Internet is cooperating
this is a data set of Arabic characters
so what you're gonna do is you're gonna
go to that link you should have all
downloaded this data set did anyone not
get it we have that look over here if
people need it okay cool so we're gonna
get this data set and then again you're
gonna go into your data sets folder
you're gonna go to Arabic characters and
you're gonna dump the files here and
we're gonna do what we've done before
let's see the characters so this is very
similar to the image problem except
instead of having ten digits in this
case allowed 28 Arabic letters and so
the label that you see on top of the
image it's corresponding to the index of
that letter in the Arabic alphabet so
Aleph is a 1 but it's a 2 to the 3 until
you get to here
at 28 okay so in this exercise try let's
not use the brain make I want you to
build a model or a brain that would
learn these digits using carrots if you
actually try to use the green that's not
gonna work it will give you an error so
I want you to look into the code of the
brain and I'll also show the sample of
code today that I just shared I'll keep
it on the screen look through that
notebook and try to write the Kyra's
model that would make this learn now if
you look at the size of this data set
remember that shape yes
so here we have 13,000 440 and it's a 32
by 32 image so the data set here is
actually a lot smaller than what we've
had before and at the same time the
number of labels in this case it's 28
it's a lot higher so the number of
examples for every label is a lot less
so you'd expect that the grain wouldn't
be able to learn as well as it did with
the other one because you had a lot more
data for it but try it out see what
numbers you can get any questions before
we move on to the coding part the fun
part oh yeah so let's let's look at that
actually a little bit more closely so if
I go to let's say here here I made a
prediction of this image and what I'm
gonna do instead is I'm gonna use Cara's
directly here predict I think this works
see I'll need to check the syntax
or PC
[Music]
all three dimensions
Oh missing one second
I'll get this
go need to look at the comment to get to
you but the output if you use the model
dot predict that I was trying to use
here I'll figure out the syntax shortly
it actually outputs the probabilities of
each of the layers the output layers so
each of the ton that is almost
impossible for you to have two numbers
to be exactly the same because these
numbers have very high precision and so
it's almost impossible in which case it
takes just one phone but that's a rare
occasion just takes one at random
yeah but I'll show you that code in a
second once I get the syntax any other
questions
here tonight that's right that's right
that's a very good question so
Carris is actually a wrapper on top so
typically these days actually let me
back up right now and the question was
what is the difference between carrots
and tensorflow
so in the early days of neural networks
everything was trained on the CPU which
is pretty much what we're doing right
now and later as neural networks became
a bigger thing it actually requires a
lot of as we saw there's a lot of
matrices there's a lot of vectors
there's a lot of scalar multiplication
that's going on there so there's a lot
of matrices involved and GPUs thanks to
the gaming industry are remarkably good
at that so we started moving from
training on the cpu the training on the
GPU tensorflow
came about to help out with the problem
of I have many many GPUs in a training a
large network and I want to distribute
the computation across multiple GPUs
Carris is actually a layer on top of
tensorflow so it actually let me just
get a notepad so the the flow that you
have if you're using the GPU is you have
right now Kharis that's like think of
that as like the top layer and
afterwards that can be using that caris
as a wrapper to several libraries so you
can use tensorflow
[Music]
or you can use another equivalent
library called Theano
and in turn these libraries what they do
is
they take the commands that you give
them and then they compile them into a
language called CUDA and CUDA is the
language that's used for NVIDIA chips
that are currently used for training
large neural networks so Karis as a
higher level API than tensorflow
it's a simpler API to use but in the
backend you could be using tensorflow
if you look at the notebook here it says
using Theano back-end if I can change
that so I can open up the Karis config
so here I'm choosing to fiona's my
back-end I can change that and put in
tensorflow and assuming the tensorflow
is installed if I reinforce this I
should just restart
you know it's using tensorflow so i have
reconfigured Kerris to use tons of flow
in this case as opposed to Fiona
and another thing that you can actually
configure in the JSON you can actually
in this configuration file you can
change it from training on the CPU or in
the GPU versus the CPU here and I do not
have a CUDA GPU so this is not going to
be possible but in cases where you
actually want to take this further what
I usually do is I would rent on Amazon I
would rent an instance with an NVIDIA
GPU and then I would do my training
there so I would only pay for the number
of hours but it use it's like a 19 cents
an hour or something in which case here
I would configure it to be using to be
using the GPU and it's orders of
magnitude faster like something that
would have taken multiple hours would
take less than a minute on the nvidia
GPU that were using and so some of you
may have configured Theano
some of you may have tensorflow
configured and so some of you most see
tensorflow as the backend
others would see Theon once the backend
but it shouldn't change anything
any other questions yeah okay
okay exercise to everyone give it a try
let me know if you're stuck you're
having any trouble off you go
you have been some
you
okay okay is anyone still working on
exercise to Diane and Hasan you guys are
working on exercise to anyone still
working on exercise - okay and so we're
gonna officially wrap the workshop now
and then we can work together to make
the exercises work for everyone just a
small little comment I want to talk
about what was covered in the workshop
and what we didn't cover
I'm just for you to get a sense of the
scope of the things we talked about so
there are different types of machine
learning problems the type of machine
problem and the machine learning problem
that we were looking at is called a
classification problem and
classification you're giving an input
and then you have a certain defined set
of categories and you want a map that
input to a category so in the case of
the digits you had ten digits you take
an image and then you map it to one of
these ten digits in the case of the
characters you had in the case of Arabic
28 characters and you take an image and
you map into one of these 28 characters
so this is called a classification
problem so we looked at specifically
image classification an image is
slightly special because in images
realize there are all the same size all
the images that we had on the data set
there were 28 by 28 or 32 by 32 now
there are certain types of
classifications where the input is not
the same size so you can't just have the
first layer process the whole input the
endpoint can be variable for example in
the case of text or in the case of
speech this is a variable input so that
is something that we didn't talk about
and there are techniques to incorporate
that into neural networks other types of
machine learning problems is for example
what is called a regression so instead
of defining taking an input and giving
out a specific category you take an
input and you give out a number so for
example I want to build a brain that
would compute that would predict the
price of rent in Beirut based on the
current prices so this is known as a
regression
problem there is no categories they
classify to the output here is a number
there's also another class of problems
that is known as reinforcement so in
this case you're actually learning as
you're going like playing chess or
playing checkers those types of games so
we've scratched the surface of what
machine learning is because we had so
little time
also we specifically talked about neural
networks it is my belief that neural
mech networks is probably the most
powerful machine learning model or type
of brain out there having said that it's
not the only one there are many models
like support vector machines like naive
Bayes plenty of different models that
you can use but I think I tried I
decided to focus on neural networks
because I felt would be the most
valuable to understand and I think the
theory behind and how it ties to biology
is something that's very interesting as
well so this is what we covered for the
workshop I'm hoping it was helpful I'm
hoping it inspired you to dig deeper
into this field if you have any feedback
for me about the workshop I also love to
stay in touch I'll be sending out my
contact information I would love to stay
in touch and if you run into any issues
if you want to continue working on the
exercises on your own or whatever
problems that you run into the future or
if you just want to say hi please do
what love to keep that in touch and that
is a wrap and for the people that are
still working on the exercise I'll come
and make sure that you get it working
[Applause]
[Music]